before we open ChemDraw let's take a
moment to discuss the main toolbar at
the top we have a lasso and marquee
which are both selection tools the lasso
allows you to draw a free-form shape to
make your selection and the marquee is a
rectangular selection tool structure
perspective allows you to select a drawn
structure and reorient it to better show
three dimensionality the various
fragmentation tools let you easily split
up a complex molecule to consider
retrosynthetic fragments the text tool
allows you to type atom labels or add
text to your drawings
if you click with the eraser tool
selected you can delete one bond at a
time for example converting a double
bond to a single bond clicking and
holding allows you to erase larger areas
of structure and text the solid bond
draws a stereochemistry undefined' bond
clicking on an atom of a molecule that
is already drawn will place the bond as
close as possible to a 120 degree bond
angle clicking the atom and dragging
allows you to place the bond at your own
preferred angle the multiple bonds tool
allows you to generate a variety of
different types of bonds with the dashed
hashed bold wedged and hollow edge you
can show stereochemistry at a Center and
indicate if a bond is pointing away from
you or toward you the wavy bond
indicates a mixture of up-and-down at a
chiral Center and is used to indicate
that a carbene is a mixture of r and s
stereo isomers the pen tools allow you
to draw curved lines the arrow tools
allow you to show reactions in
retrosynthesis show equilibrium and
resonance and draw your own mechanisms
using curved arrow notation
you can add molecular orbital's to any
atom using the orbitals tools the
drawing and bracket tools permit you to
make a variety of shapes I often use
this tool to box important structures
with the chemical symbol tools you can
add lone pairs and charges to your
molecules the query tools allow you to
label chiral molecules tables can be
created with the table tools and TLC
plates drawn with the chromatography
tools you can then adjust the RF of your
spots the chain tools allow you to draw
long carbon chains while counting carbon
atoms for you this is great for drawing
fatty acids and other molecules with
long carbon chains spend some time
looking through the templates these are
great time savers as an example of some
of the capabilities there are templates
for all of the amino acids by cyclic
compounds chair cyclohexane and Newman
projections there's even some chemistry
and biology clip are available in this
menu the rest of the tools allow you to
generate various saturated and
unsaturated rings with a click which you
can further modify with any of the other
tools clicking the middle of a bond with
the cyclohexane tools for example allows
you to draw fused rings while clicking
on a single atom allows you to quickly
generate a Spiro cyclic structure now
that we've had a quick overview of the
main toolbar I will demonstrate how to
quickly generate high-quality figures
and schemes for this basic tutorial I
will show several ways to generate
structures evaluate stereochemistry with
a click and show the basics of scheme
drawing when you open chem draw the view
will look something like this
I'm going to use the benzene ring tool
to draw the compound pyridine notice how
small the nitrogen atom looks against
the bonds the default settings for chem
draw
do not give good Adam to bond size
ratios to correct this apply ACS
settings to all of your documents
through the file menu you can do this by
selecting open stationery and select ACS
document 1996 or you can apply the
setting to the current document through
the file menu using apply document
settings to begin let's look at the
amino acid l-alanine first I'll
demonstrate how to draw this compound
using the drawing tools we'll begin by
drawing a bond in the vertical direction
which I'll make into the carbonyl group
as a shortcut I can use the solid bond
tool to click on a single bond and
convert it to a double bond note that
you can also generate double bonds with
the multiple bond tools as well as
triple bonds and several other bond
types now that I have a skeleton for
alanine drawn it's time to add my hetero
atoms or non carbon atoms I can click on
the text tool and type my label or with
the bond tool still selected I can
double click to type my labels now all
that's left is to add stereochemistry I
want to generate the enantiomer
of the amino acid found in humans which
is commonly called the L enantiomer all
amino acids in the human body are L as
opposed to D amino acids to relate this
to R and s nomenclature system all amino
acids found in humans are s with the
exception of cysteine a faster way to
draw l-alanine is to use its IU pack or
a you pack accepted common name in the
structure menu use the convert name to
structure command and type l-alanine
notice that this structure is oriented
differently than the structure I drew
manually vancomycin is a complex
antibiotic and its structure is not
readily generated from its I you pack
name and ChemDraw as it contains
/ scripted numbers in this case we can
use the simplified molecular input line
entry system or smiles for short
this smile string can be used to quickly
generate this complex structure in a web
browser I will search vancomycin smiles
my first hit is from pubchem which is a
good source I'll navigate to this web
page and copy the isomeric smiles string
now in the Edit paste special menu of
ChemDraw I can paste as smiles quickly
generating vancomycin structure the IU
pack international chemical identifier
or I n CH I string is another type of
structure abbreviation that can be used
to quickly produce structures in
ChemDraw
let's return to our amino acid to
explore stereochemistry which is easily
examined using ChemDraw when we
right-click on the stereo Center the
menu that pops up contains an option to
show stereochemistry with that selected
we now see the s label come up on our
structure indicating this is the S
enantiomer at the chiral Center within
the context of showing stereochemistry
we need to look at the two ways we can
reorient structures using ChemDraw as
one method will preserve our
stereochemistry and the other will
invert it changing it to the R
enantiomer I'm going to copy/paste our
structure to illustrate this in the
object menu there are two options to
manipulate the structure at the bottom
flip and rotate first I'll apply the
flip command notice that the entire
structure flips including the stereo
Center this compound has now changed to
the R enantiomer and has flipped 180
degrees this is useful for representing
enantiomers as being reflected through a
mirror plane and I'll use my drawing
tools to draw a dotted line to represent
that plane now if we rotate the
structure using the rotate menu item the
Serio Center rotates along with the
structure and stereochemistry is
preserved you can also show the
stereochemistry of e and z double bonds
using the show stereochemistry command
I'll demonstrate this with the two
isomers of 2-butene I can draw my double
bond first and then click on the
terminal carbon atoms to finish the
structure this first structure has the
high priority groups on opposite sides
and thus is the e double bond now let's
look at the Z isomer when I click the
terminal carbon atoms ChemDraw
automatically generates the e isomer
again
if I use the undo command either by
typing ctrl + Z or using the undo button
in the toolbar at the top of ChemDraw
when I click on the terminal Adam again
using the bond tool notice it creates
the Z isomer whenever two orientations
are available for a newly drawn bond the
undo command will allow you to redraw
the bond in the second orientation with
a click this works for both sp2 and sp3
centers if at any point in the process
of drawing structures you move or drag a
bond into an unpaired orientation you
can use the structure menu to fix it
select clean up structure and Kendra
will correct your bond angles for you
in solution close to neutral pH amino
acids exist as wither ions using the
chemical symbol tools we can easily add
these charges and the necessary hydrogen
atoms using l-alanine once again let's
add a negative charge to the carboxylic
acid to form a carboxylate I'll click my
single bonded oxygen atom and place my
negative charge
notice that the H atom automatically
disappears now let's add the necessary
protons to the amine group this time I'm
going to draw out all three protons that
the amine group will have in its sweater
ionic form notice when I add my final
hydrogen atom that nitrogen becomes
illuminated with the red chemical
warning box whenever nitrogen has four
bonds it is positively charged so kendra
is indicating a mistake in the structure
when I add my positive charge the
chemical warning disappears note that I
could have simply added a positive
charge to the nitrogen atom in the first
place
and ChemDraw updates the number of
hydrogen atoms automatically but here I
wanted to draw out all of my hydrogen
atoms now let's explore the arrow tools
a bit more by looking at resonance in
equilibrium and then we'll finish by
drawing a simple reaction mechanism this
would on ik form of alanine has an
equivalent resonance structure so let's
first use ChemDraw to show this
resonance first I'm going to use the
chemical symbol tools to show all lone
pairs on our oxygen atoms note that when
I click on the oxygen atom I can draw
the lone pair associated with it into
whatever orientation that I want
now by clicking-and-dragging
we can pull out the arrows tool menu
let's select our resonance arrow and
place it next to Allen II now we can
select a curved arrow to show this lone
pair on the negatively charged oxygen
forming a double bond
and the double bond to this oxygen
breaking to become a lone pair on oxygen
remember resonance forms are not
separate structures that the compound
oscillates or inter converts between
even though sometimes it looks that way
in fact resonance forms are a construct
that allows us to gain a better picture
of the overall structure of a molecule
the real structure is a weighted average
of the resonance forms that we can show
for a given molecule with better
resonance forms contributing more we can
also represent this average structure as
a resonance hybrid using partial bonds
and partial charges using the multiple
bond tool select the half solid half
dashed bond to represent these partial
bonds now we can add partial charges in
the view menu find the character map
window which contains useful symbols and
Greek letters select the lower case
Delta and add negative charges to
represent the partial charge on each
oxygen atom
sometimes a compound is in equilibrium
with another compound a simple example
of this is the partial ionization of a
weak acid in water when an aqueous
solution of acetic acid is made for
example some of its conjugate base or
acetate forms along with a proton which
we can represent as the hydronium ion
you
now we need to show an equilibrium arrow
I'm going to select the unbalanced
equilibrium arrow to show that most of
the compound remains onion eyes notice
the water and hydronium ion requires sub
and super scripting this can be done
using these buttons
however ChemDraw makes this process even
easier with the formula button select
everything you want to convert to a
formula and simply click the ch2 button
here I'd like to note that ChemDraw
automatically enters formula mode when
you are typing directly on to structures
that you've created with the bond or
ring tools when an aqueous solution of
an amino acid is treated with acid the
carboxylate group gets protonated we can
show the mechanism of this reaction
using curved arrows again using alanine
let's show the mechanism of the reaction
of an amino acid with the hydronium ion
you
show an arrow originating from the
nucleophilic oxygen atom we can show
either an electron pair or the negative
charge attacking the proton of the
hydronium ion by pointing to the
hydrogen atom where the new bond forms
to complete our mechanism we must show
the electron pair that was bonded to the
hydrogen atom becoming a lone pair on
oxygen
this reaction gives us protonated
alanine and a molecule of water we can
copy-paste the alanine zwitterion and
then modify the structure to show the
product
you
notice that you can change the curviness
of the mechanism arrow after drawing
ChemDraw is a powerful program that can
be used to quickly generate and
manipulate structures it's true
capabilities are beyond the scope of
this introductory tutorial I refer you
to the PerkinElmer site for additional
tutorials and to link to the ChemDraw
manual